so NBC News put out an article claiming
that 2020 Democratic candidate Beto
O'Rourke is raising money more quickly
than Bernie Sanders for their respective
candidacies the headline from the
article says O'Rourke raises nine point
four million in 18 days a faster pace
than Sanders so there are two problems
here one problem is that bado
is not actually out raising Bernie
Sanders not outpacing Bernie Sanders in
fundraising and I'm gonna break that
down for you in a second the other
problem once again is the author of this
article
Alex cites Wald who keeps writing stuff
for NBC News without it being disclosed
that he's a tool of the Democratic
establishment which I've told you about
before and I'm also going to get back to
in a second but let me first deal with
the claim about the pace of fundraising
then we'll deal with the author what
does the article actually say let's take
a look at that first quote O'Rourke
reported raising nine point four million
in the first quarter at an average
contribution of $43 a pop well short of
Bernie Sanders 18 million and the 12
million senator Colin Harris said she
raised but O'Rourke's campaign noted
that the Texan entered the race much
later than the others giving him only 18
days to fundraise before the March 31st
deadline compared with the 41 days
Sanders had between his February launch
and the end of the quarter or Harris's
70 days following her January
announcement and they go on to break
this down and they say look bado raised
five hundred and twenty-two thousand
dollars a day in each of his first 18
days in q1 and Bernie raised four
hundred and forty thousand dollars per
day during q1 in the 41 days that he was
raising money so clearly better or
Rorick is raising money faster right not
really there are so many issues with
this that it's hard to break them all
down but I'm going to try number one the
fundraising curve of campaigns is not
linear what I mean by that is you would
expect that until you have major data
points
move the needle like for example the
debate start or candidates start
dropping out which funnels more
donations to the people that are left
you raise more money when you first
announce then when your campaign
campaign sort of settles down and you
raise less later on it's sort of trails
off
Bernie announced 41 days ago and raised
ten million dollars in his first week
beta O'Rourke announced a or tur time
ago and raised way less in his first
week and then okay both of them sort of
trailed off but what you have to
understand is that in their first weeks
Bernie raised way more than beta or work
in their first 12 days
Bernie raised way more than beta
O'Rourke what they're saying is that
Bernie Sanders has been in the race for
much longer and thus more recently if
you divide his fundraising by more days
it appears as though beta or work is
actually raising money more quickly but
this is not the case now I'm going to
give you two examples to try to make
this crystal clear this would apply to
areas that I sort of know a little bit
about learning about drums and chess
okay these are two subjects that I've
studied in both of those areas when you
first start learning you make big
improvements like in your first month
when you start learning drums or you
start learning chess you make rapid
improvements and then it starts to get
harder to move the needle you start to
plateau the gains become smaller and it
becomes more and more difficult to
improve as quickly so imagine that I
said to you look this person's been
learning drums or chess for three months
and this other person's been learning
drums or chess for six months the person
who has been learning for only three
months their improvement per day is way
higher than the person who's been
learning for six months well yeah
because people's learning slows down
after your initial significant
advancements in your knowledge about a
subject so if they honestly wanted to
make the comparison between Bernie's
fundraising pace and better or works
raising pace they would say okay how did
each of them do during their first week
well Bernie crushed better or ork
how did each of them do during their
first 18 days
Bernie crushed beta or ork only if you
look at 41 days of Bernie fundraising
and 18 days of bado fundraising do you
get this conclusion and it is very very
deceptive and it's straight out of the
book how to lie with statistics you can
put this under the chapter the
well-chosen average strategically
picking averages that are favorable to
your point of view read that book by the
way if you haven't really important
you'd recognize this right away if you
had read the book
so it's a very dishonest and deceptive
claim now let's get to the important
stuff even if you raise more money or
you raise money more quickly doesn't
mean you're a better candidate even if
you raise more money it doesn't tell us
whether the money is coming from
small or large donors even if you raise
more money doesn't necessarily tell us
who's going to win although it actually
gives us a pretty good hint because in
general in our political system if you
raise more money you win very very often
but if you're going to focus on who is
raising more money tell us the truth and
don't do it deceptively so that's that
now let's get back to the writer of this
article
Alex Seitz Walt I've talked about Alex
Seitz Walt before Alex cites Wald
is one of the assistant editors of Think
Progress org which is part of the Center
for American Progress is Action Fund
which is a main player in the Democratic
Party at this point it's headed up by
Neera tanden who was a member of Hillary
Clinton's advisors in the 2016 primaries
they are the Democratic establishment
and Al excites Wald was involved in what
just stunk of astroturf back in December
with an article about the non-existent
Bernie war on bado and this reeks of
more of the same astroturf and it's
really important any time you see a
headline research for yourself and do
the work and you will very often uncover
that it claims like this one about the
fundraising pace of beta or Oracle
Bernie Sanders are extraordinarily
deceptive if not completely dishonest at
the core one of the day's sponsors is
privacy dot-com / Pakman which is a free
service that I myself use really useful
in many different ways takes just a few
seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link